The dramatic narratives of the geologic past are perfectly suited to the human
appetite for storytelling. Like many who
experienced childhood or parenthood in
the last 50 years, I loved Maurice
Sendak's 'Where the Wild Things Are.' It's
a book about the power of imagination to take us to other worlds, transcend time
and save us from our worst selves.
I think of Max's voyage whenever I teach
'History of Earth and Life,' a course in
which we cover Earth's 4 and 1/2 billion
year history in a 10-week term at an
average clip of about 450 million years
a week. I always feel that I've been on
a long journey with my students. We've
witnessed alien earths, explored
alternate ecosystems teeming with
strange wild things, through bountiful times and bad ones.
Finally, we approach the present and see
the modern world emerging from the mists
just as Max's room gradually sheds its
vines and becomes recognizable again. I
believe, perhaps naively, that if more
people could experience this journey and
see themselves as earthlings with a common past and shared destiny it might
spring us out of our polarized and entrenched ways of thinking about the
world. As a geologist, I've worked with
people from all over the world, from very
different cultures and generations, older
and younger than mine. The strong human
connections I've developed with them through our shared study of earth make
me optimistic that a geocentric, timeful
worldview might help us overcome the
animosities and barriers that divide us
and get down to work on things that
really matter. Collective awareness of Earth's story
might save us from environmental hubris. Understanding how historical
happenstance is written into each of our personal lives might cause us to treat
each other with more empathy. And a timeful habit of mine might even make us
less neurotic about the fact of our own
mortality by shifting our focus from the
finite lengths of our lives to the rich anthology of experiences that a lifetime
represents. While other senses may be
dulled with age, the sense of time which
can only be developed by experiencing it, is heightened. Growing old requires one
to shed the illusion that there's only
one version of the world.